Lisa's an Oshkosh Wisconsin hi Lisa how
are you just fine Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up well
it's an honor to speak with you this is
actually my second or third time I can't
remember I spoke to you about a year ago
because I had this idea that I was going
to pay off the house after I cashed out
some stock with my company from a former
job but you said it wasn't gonna be
enough to pay it off and I really should
stick it in my retirement since I had
put it in there for a while any
retirement funds so what I did was I
can't shop a stock and I put it in the
bank
and then I sat on it for a year and it's
sitting thanks right now
you know gathering guys collecting like
0.001 percent interest and the problem
is my husband and I are at a
disagreement about what to do with the
money because the financial broker that
we're using kind of made a boo-boo when
I rolled over my IRA to him with my
husband's IRA the four of us I mean the
two of us rolled over four accounts so
it was kind of confusing for them but
what they ended up doing was I put my
Roth money into a traditional IRA and so
I didn't catch it until I was actually
doing taxes and by then a year had
passed and they didn't believe me and it
took me like a week of losing sleep and
kind of having to garner evidence from
you know my former employer to show that
I had given them both funds there was
two different funds Roth and non-rock
and he kind of just laughed at me and
said we don't make mistakes you're
mistaken and my husband says I should
just forget it and forgive which you
know we're Christians we believe in
forgiveness we believe in tithing but I
have this big chunk of money I want to
max out my IRA for the year and I just
at Class A shares you know you give this
to the guy and it's five percent off the
top and I know he's not going to make
another mistake as I'm gonna watch him
like a hawk but I know I could just do
it myself you know if I just opened up
my own account and rolled it over but
then I'm leaving my husband behind
because we both use the same investor
and I know emotionally it feels like I'm
just divided from my husband
we if I walk away and find a new way
place to invest in fast fat IRA
okay well let's clarify something okay
when Christians are called to forgive
there's a difference between forgiveness
and reconciliation uh-huh
okay if someone abuses your child would
be one of the worst possible things you
could think of right right I don't know
how I could forgive them I'd probably
kill them but only if I but I'm called
as a Christian to forgive them right
that does not mean I hire them as a
babysitter the next week that's the
difference in forgiveness and
reconciliation
okay forgiveness does not mean you
submit yourself to someone stealing your
wallet again you know huh that's the
difference in reconciliation and
forgiveness you cannot be reconciled and
still have forgiven it means I don't
know anything to do with them but I've
forgiven them okay all right and so that
lets separate those two clearly and from
a spiritual standpoint now once we've
covered that I don't think this is a
financial problem I think this is a
problem with you and your husband and I
think the two of you are going to have
to reconcile you're either going to have
to accept that this guy is competent and
made one simple error the problem is not
the error though the problem is the
arrogance and the way you were treated
yeah and the fact that your husband
doesn't back you on that is a little
troubling mm-hmm okay so you smell a rat
you've got a problem with this guy and I
got to tell you I'm the financial guy I
work with financial people all the time
we've got accounts we've got investments
we've got all these different things
going on and if my wife says I will not
work with this guy anymore then we have
to put the brakes on even though she
doesn't know the details I mean she's
probably not as well-versed as you sound
like you are yeah but she understands
our investments but you're neck deep in
this stuff you got your fingers down in
it okay but and you know but even though
she's not as doesn't have her fingers is
far into it maybe
you do if she's got a bad feeling about
the guy mm-hmm we don't work there
anymore we have to change but for two
reasons one is proverbs 31 says who can
find a virtuous wife for her worth is
far above rubies the heart of her
husband safely trusts her and he will
have no lack of gain and so every time I
go against one of Sharon's feelings it
cost me a minimum of 10 grand I quit
doing it yeah I like that
okay no but she doesn't miss place that
and become arrogant because it says a
virtuous wife right so that means she
doesn't play that trump card
hardly ever but if she says that guy's a
bad guy that gals a bad gal then you
know what I don't do deals away though
you know and the fact that this guy if
this guy mistreated my wife that way a
bit arrogant to her you know that would
have the end of the thing for me and
that's not because you're I'm being
chivalrous or something like that well
that's because it's a financial
principle I have no lack of gain because
my wife and I stay in unity do you see
the thing for me it's a financial
pragmatist principle and that's that's
where I want you and your husband to get
back to on this and again that may be
kind of a spiritual decision on between
the two of you and then you fire this
guy and you move your and you move your
accounts the second you don't recommend
us taking all of our nothing not like
show them up no I would I would move
everything hmm because you don't trust
him well see and he also manages his 401
k's not company you can we're not really
diversified when you look at it for me
no no that's that I don't mind one
person having all your accounts I that's
not that's not a diversification issue
diversification is where the investments
are placed not who's the broker who the
adviser is well then just one more quick
thing then one other issue and let me
finish and then all that can go to one
more quick thing okay the other problem
is if he dies this is your guy the you
don't trust your husband dies if my wife
if I die and my wife has a guy that she
don't trust
and that's who she's got to call up and
start managing the money with that's a
problem that's a problem right and vice
versa if I don't trust the guy we're not
doing deals with him because if I share
andaaz I got a deal with you know and
something that she's working on whatever
so anyway now your second part was what
well since we've already rolled over to
this stockbroker and it was a five
percent off the top commission if we
turn around and roll it over again we're
talking about roughly a hundred thousand
dollars going to another broker then
isn't that going to be a second five
percent off the tops they're going to be
losing probably if you stay within the
fund family probably not if you just
keep it in the same funds and move it to
a different managing broker problem okay
I never thought of that
well good idea because your fun choice
is not your question it's the guy way
the guy treated you and and even the
mistake is not a problem everybody makes
mistakes right
I made some this morning I'm sure I
probably made some on the air today
you know everybody makes mistakes the
only question is how you deal with it
when you have mistake and treating my
wife arrogantly when you screwed up is a
really bad reaction to having made a
mistake really bad you know so you know
papper on her little head but give me a
break
unbelievable this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]